[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah yes so much to be happy
about people love the show Always Sunny
in Philadelphia it's become a real
cultural phenomenon but also to you
congratulations you had a baby how many
days ago two days ago two days ago wow
congratulations little baby boy little
baby about this big well okay we don't
even know exactly how stop crushing your
baby uh what is the name of this uh
miles Robert Howerton oh I like the name
miles how'd you come up with that name
uh you know what it was a last resort
thing my wife and I yeah my wife and I
thought it would be a good idea to wait
to see the baby first uh before we
actually decided what his name would be
that wasn't a good idea because we we
thought well it would be good to get a
sense of the guy you know I mean get a
little sense of him before we actually
land on his name and then we saw him and
he looked like a tiny little baby alien
Grandpa
creature and I was like I'm not getting
any information from this along with
alien Grandpa you could have gone with
the second name on our list Andy that
was the the second name on our list see
one with Miles yeah yeah we couldn't
agree on anything else did you have a
list of possible names before you it was
it was entirely too long Conan it was a
really long list right yeah it was like
Nigel on it why why not I don't know I
just my job is to ask questions and
that's a question did you just pull that
out of nowhere yeah Cedric Cedric was
not on Mortimer no but you know what was
what Conan what's Conan on the list no I
didn't think so
nobody names their kid Conan uh but
Conan was oh man
[Applause]
uh on the show uh you uh you have
displayed your singing and dancing
prowess yeah and It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia in fact let's start with a
little clip here for anyone who hasn't
seen you at work I would say that
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I couldn't help but notice uh you like
to really get up into that high register
I do indeed yeah yeah yeah I like
getting up there it's fun because you
know it's nice to have a large I'm like
Josh Groban I was gonna say you're a lot
like Josh Groban yeah yeah I have an
extraordinary range yeah and I like to
now can we hear a little sample like how
high do you like to how high can you go
you want to see how high I can yeah yeah
let's see let's do something here right
now I don't I mean I'm not warmed up or
anything but I can okay all right
uh okay I'll just I'll step it up how
about that we'll step it up
[Applause]
we got you got something I can't get up
that hard
I can't I can't get up there you look
just like my baby I look just like your
baby yeah
your baby when your baby was born it was
like
it was something like that our baby's
becoming Adam Sandler
[Music]
[Laughter]